I gotta ask how you're doing because
we're at the end of a season where
you've been traveling across the country
all season long ultimately how have
these cross-country flights made you
feel sure I enjoy going back and forth
cuz I get to come home here to LA
tonight I don't have to sleep on a plane
because we have the finale tomorrow so
I'm kind of excited to sleep on my my in
my own bed with my pillows but it has
been it's been doable I get less I get
less sleep on the Sunday Monday I really
don't sleep so by Tuesday I'm tired
alright so just some I don't know Diet
Coke and a prayer I guess one ask you
also about season two what adjustments
would you want to see be made if any any
changes you want to make make things
bigger better I honestly think that we
couldn't extend the season a little bit
I think that we built some great
momentum coming into this week but I
almost want a little more as you get
down to that final group people start to
vote for their favorites and talk about
them so maybe a little more next year
[Music]